bananas from South America Footwear from
China textiles from Turkey sometimes
good the soul to Europe at very low
prices called dumping which may threaten
European industries and jobs
to counter this anti dumping fees are
imposed in the world of global trade
there are two main types of economies a
market economy and a non market economy
in a market economy prices are
determined by rules of supply and demand
with limited government interference in
a non market economy prices can be set
by the state one of the easiest biggest
trade partners China is treated as a non
market economy this means higher
anti-dumping fees China has asked the EU
to granted a market economy status but
with the new law classifications won't
matter the EU Commission can decide how
much duties to impose based on criteria
such as state interference in the
country and not on the type of economy
known a un protection is mama a un
Ostrom ento can see Boni al Centro la
Nietzsche see takechi sia una libera
concurrence a dimer car Toman el oso
tempo a para cada condiciones the
European Parliament is scrutinizing the
new legislation to ensure that the
meaning and the scope of the criteria
are crystal clear the aim fair trade
conditions for EU companies